if there was like One supplement that I
get asked about the most on my weekly
amas or in comment sections it's
creatine and honestly I probably avoided
talking about it casually because
there's just so much here to unpack
especially in the context of women's
fitness body composition and overall
health so if you're a woman and you've
ever considered adding creatine to your
stack you definitely need to watch this
first hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome back to my channel
[Music]
thank you
in today's video I will be chatting all
things creatine for women how it can
enhance or affect your weight body
composition mental health and your
productive life cycle but also at what
cost a quick note here that we are
talking about body composition and fat
loss today so please feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and also please note that I
am using the term women for brevity here
today even though I acknowledge that the
biological effects that I'm discussing
could also apply to folks who do not
identify as a woman and a big thank you
to the team at unlocked Fitness for
their expert support on this video these
are my preferred RDS for any weight loss
or Sports Nutrition needs so definitely
check out their link below for
one-on-one Support also don't forget to
hit out my description for my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook And
subscribe if you are not already okay
first let me quickly hop in here to tell
you about my sponsor loaming so my
family and I are really into gardening
my husband is definitely the Green Thumb
in the family but I love benefiting from
it when I can just like walk outside my
yard and it feels like my own little
secret Oasis I feel like it's been a
really important Hands-On teaching tool
for my kids it's important to me that
they understand where their food comes
from and that they're already starting
to think about ways to help support the
environment taking care of our planet is
one of our favorite things to talk about
I mean my eldest is already quite the
environmentalist so when I heard about
loamy I was really excited to add
another step to our gardening lessons
with our kids loamy is a countertop
electrical composter that transforms
food scraps and waste into soil in four
hours not only has to significantly
reduced the organic food waste that
we're putting out for the garbage truck
each week but we get nutrient dense soil
for our garden and plants my son told
his camp counselor very proudly that
he's been helping the Earth get healthy
after all the forest fires near home and
I don't know that just as a mom that
just makes me so proud so if you're
getting to gardening or trying to find
little ways to cut back on your food
waste check out loamy.com com slash ABI
in the description and use my promo code
Abby to get 50 off of your loamy okay so
a quick little overview here folks
creatine is a peptide made up of three
amino acids methionine Glycine and
Arginine without getting too into like
the Nitty Gritty of what creatine
actually does just know that creatine
can regenerate ADP or adenosine
diphosphate into a TP or adenosine
triphosphate and ATP is our energy
source at the cellular level the human
body produces approximately one gram of
creatine per day women specifically
biosynthesize a bit less so around 0.8
grams per day we also could get it from
red meat and seafood which amounts to
about one to two grams per day so for
most omnivores are creatine stores sit
around 60 to 80 percent full women tend
to fall on like the lower end of this
range because they typically have diets
lower in creatine than men dido4 and
vegetarians and vegans whose stores
generally only reach about 55 to 65
percent saturation so the goal of
creatine supplementation is to get these
stores as close to 100 as possible to
help improve strength and exercise
performance now the reason why I've been
asked about creatine literally a million
times is that it's not just another
semi-boga supplement it is truly
powerful stuff
power creatine is often referred to as
the most effective ergogenic nutritional
supplement for increasing high intensity
Exercise capacity and lean body mass
during exercise and while men typically
are bigger users than women they're
actually a unique number of benefits for
women so first let's just quickly talk
about its primary use exercise
performance and by association body
composition because exercise improves
workout performance and allows you to
train with more intensity it can induce
greater adaptations to exercise by
improving strength power and muscle size
all but one of the studies in this 2021
review of the literature that
specifically tested the effects of
creatine on women observed faster
improvements in strength exercise
performance and also sprinting time
creatine can also significantly increase
lean body mass in both Advanced female
athletes and folks who are relatively
new to exercise which could be
incredibly encouraging for a lot of
Fitness newbies it is important to know
here that you can't just like take
creatine and expect massive gains in
lean body mass unless you are an older
adult for whom we do see some
improvements in strength even without
exercise from creatine you still do need
to put in the work
and work now when you hear significant
increases in lean body mass you probably
are thinking about weight loss or fat
loss so let's talk about this because
it's often the promise of fat loss that
draws people into using supplements like
creatine okay folks don't get at me here
but creatine does not result in fat or
weight loss in fact it may actually make
the number on the scale go up a little
bit because the increase in lean mass
includes both muscle and some water that
it's stored with both of which can
increase the number on the scale so of
course this is a really good time to
remind everyone why said number is BS
because if you're training harder and
you're gaining muscle you're gonna look
a little bit leaner so fat loss and
weight loss is not a major benefit of
creatine but improved body composition
can be and speaking of unique benefits
there may also be some use for creatine
supplements for blood sugar control so
creatine seems to increase the function
of glucose transporter Type 4 which then
brings circulating glucose to the
muscles and out of the blood as a result
one 12-week study found that those who
combined creatine with exercise improved
their blood sugar control better than
those who exercised alone now this data
is still very exploratory but with the
growing interest in blood sugar
management right now I do think it is
some pretty exciting research to watch
now what I find fascinating and unique
about creatine is that it not only
improves physical performance and health
but also mental performance so it turns
out that creatine can give you both the
brains and the bronze so let's talk
about women creatine and depression so
depression is about twice as prevalent
in young women versus men and there are
many psychosocial reasons for this but
it may also be potentially linked to
hormonal fluctuations of estrogen and
progesterone research has actually
examined the role of altered creatine
metabolism and depression and mood in
adults suggesting that low brain
creatine levels may result in low
dopamine and serotonin levels as a
result research suggests that creatine
may actually work similar to the
powerful antidepressant ketamine in
improving certain mood disorders and
since women are grossly underserved in
mental health and yet in cases of mood
disorders are typically even more in
need this finding may be huge so next
let's talk about brain function and
cognition our brains require a lot of
ATP to process difficult cognitive tasks
and guess what we do as women we process
all the difficult cognitive tasks and
usually all at once hashtag multitaskers
for life but one systematic review of
the literature found that creatine
supplementation did actually improve
short-term memory as well as
intelligence and reasoning this
Improvement is much more evident in
vegetarians and vegans who tend to be
more sensitive to supplementation than
omnivores but it's also been shown to
improve recall and protect against
neurological diseases in older adults so
yeah in my opinion this creatine has so
much far-reaching potential as a
nootropic for the general population
then as an ergonomic drug for elite
athletes so we have established that
creatine has a lot of unique and pretty
substantial benefits for the body and
for women in particular but there are
some really unique considerations for
the female life cycle so let's talk that
time of the month in folks with normal
menstrual cycles it suggested that since
protein turnover is greatest during the
lunal phase of our cycle AKA right after
ovulation and right before you get your
period creatine supplementation before
your period may actually be particularly
advantageous next let's talk about
pregnancy so pregnancy is obviously a
time of increased metabolic needs and
creatine levels actually tend to be
lower during pregnancy than any other
period in the adult lifespan now low
creatine levels during pregnancy have
been associated with low birth weight
and preterm birth and while we have
loads of rodent studies suggesting
benefits including reducing neuronal
injury seizures and chronic kidney
disease we have no human trials
evaluating the effects of creatine
supplementation during pregnancy and
that's because it's often unethical to
study pregnant women in a randomized
control trial there's currently no
reason to believe that it would be
unsafe but it's important to know that
study is like a large one that is
underway right now publish their
findings before recommendations can be
safely made finally let's talk post
menopause as we age creatine stores
muscle strength and muscle mass tend to
decline creatine has been shown to act
as a countermeasure to these menopause
related declines and may also help to
reduce inflammation and oxidative stress
and as I mentioned unlike with younger
women older adults tend to see benefits
from creatine supplementation even
without any kind of intentional exercise
so now you know that there is a ton of
benefits to creatine but the question is
at what cost is this magical supplement
even safe well for like the first time
ever yes individuals both healthy and
clinical populations who have taken
creatine for extended periods of time
AKA up to like five years have not
demonstrated any detrimental effects
from its use there could be some mild
side effects like GI bloating or cramps
or some water waking game but these are
actually rare and a lot less common in
women in terms of dosing the general
guideline is a loading phase of 0.3
grams per kilogram per five to seven
days or around 20 grams per day and then
a maintenance dose of 0.03 grams per
kilogram or about 5 grams daily If you
experience bloating or side effects you
can kind of skip the loading phase it
just might take a bit longer to see the
desirable effects while training now
whether or not you need creatine
supplements will really depend on your
life stage and goals but as always I do
recommend speaking to a dietitian like
my friends at unlocked Fitness for that
one-on-one support and on that note my
tiramisu overnight oats is looking damn
good such a good post workout snack a
great pairing with creatine I might add
but if you guys like this video be sure
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you have any more
burning questions about creatine or any
other nutrition questions that you want
me to answer and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and hit up my
description for my free Hunger crushing
combo ebook and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye bye
foreign
[Music]